welcome back to new rock stars news
today we are talking all things venom
we're also gonna cover a couple big Star
Wars stories daredevil season 3 trailer
and more guys joining me here at this
table are Sam bachelor and Phillip
Malina
of course is busy living her best life
in New York comic-con jelly oh man she
called out a picture of jello and Ryan
Gosling
she's great that's Bruce super super
cool she's you've got to go to where the
Rockettes
sleep well let's get to our main story
of course this week venom the movie is
here and the reviews are in and
everyone's got a take on this I thought
we would actually take it piece by piece
today oh and heads up for you guys it's
gonna be a spoiler review we're gonna
talk about the full movie beginning
middle and end although those things are
kind of hard to distinguish in this
movie but you know there's a lot of good
things going on with this movie I don't
want it to be too one-sided it's never
too one-sided just so you know this is
gonna be a kind of review where we're
all hating on it or we're all just like
loving it we'd try to have a more
nuanced view but let's talk about the
script of this movie the story what do
we think about the the story structure
of the characters how well did they
adapt the comic story into the movie
that we saw on screen I think the
premise of trying to take a character
that relies so heavily on a hero for
their backstory and making them their
own thing is a cool experiment that they
didn't quite nail but the bones of that
idea are good what you see in this movie
the idea that sense for their spoilers
the idea that there's an invasion force
you get the you get the buddy cop movie
but the cops are one person and like
that's a fun idea and it's upgrade but
upgrade did that I'd be a better of the
possession movie Oh Corey did like
executed so much better on this this
possession kind of thing or or a you
know passenger that's riding along with
you and like kind of communicating with
you you guys should watch up great by
the way because it executes a lot of the
things that this movie actually doesn't
so what's really interesting is is I'm
glad you brought that up because upgrade
is a much smaller film right it does not
have those global stakes it's not
talking about the end of the world and
you know potentially bringing a bunch of
other upgrade chips or something
and yet the stakes feel so like like
high and you're constantly oh my god
you know is he gonna lose like every
moment of that movie feels worse than
the moment before and I feel like
structurally and this is I do think this
is a script issue it didn't feel like
anything was like that big a deal
like weren't there like five characters
in this entire movie yeah yeah
especially considering they're going to
space and they're gonna bring back all
these things things like I'm literally
gonna fly this whole thing by myself
even five minutes
it's Rockets launching and no one it's
like it's nothing it doesn't matter
anyway
anybody does that that chop across like
the whole room I'm also like no I don't
even buy to the computer it's gonna turn
on like you can fly a rocket yeah yeah
you're right there were some escalation
issues with this movie let's I want to
get out this out of the way this does
not deserve a 29 or 30 percent of run
Tomatoes that site is too much of a
binary aggregate of it's not a fair
representation of the movie because if
you give it a 4 out of 10 you
essentially gave it a zero yeah or if
you give it a C+ it's yeah they'll weigh
it down sometimes but I think there are
some escalation issues and some
structural issues with this movie this
really does feel like a movie that was
found in the edit right like we do know
that at one point this movie was aiming
to be r-rated right which upgrade it was
and that also makes everything much more
visceral yeah this does feel like a kind
of movie that the director and the
editor and everyone I think who worked
on this movie from the writers to the
cast the director are all very competent
skilled creative people I just think at
some point there was some kind of mixed
messaging from the studio and what kind
of movie they wanted to make and
unfortunately you can see there are big
chunks of this movie that are kind of
totally inconsistent and there are times
where they really stretch out the I feel
like the first act to the movie where
they kind of start the movie before the
movie begins and kind of show you stuff
that should just be prologue maybe
explained away in exposition we don't
need to see all these events and there
are times of something have we not seen
that we would have all fallen asleep in
that first act maybe because because
those things introduced a question for
us of when is that gonna come into play
cuz I was checking in constantly and I
was like man this is way later than I
ever would have expected we still
haven't he's not he hasn't even been
exposed yet to the not symbiote by the
way did you notice a smart yeah very
smart but I
he's not even exposed to it till like
what it's more than half an hour into
the movie oh yeah so we needed that a
little bit
Dettol LJ jenna jameson son reference at
the beginning in order to care about
that at all i think the way you should
have probably started the movie this
movie is a lot similar to in some
aspects to the mask where it's like
there's there's a supernatural element
that like it's taken over someone's body
it's bringing out different elements of
them and they don't have control over it
a funny tongue but also we get that we
get the mask the mask in the first ten
minutes of that movie we don't get this
into what feels like halfway through it
might not be but it feels like it for
how slow this movie the way they reveal
it is by Tom Hardy looking at his
reflection in the car window like a
whole you know like you don't see the
shark until you don't see the venom
until you know the sharks not even in
the movie enjoy the Sharks voice no I
think honestly the way you can kind of
tighten up the story the parts that work
because there's like three different
movies you got your superhero movie
that's the end then you have the buddy
caught funny stuff with venom which
person was my favorite stuff which was
right in the middle ish area and then in
the beginning it's your super serious
grounded stuff which I actually really
liked the intro where you get the
symbiotes coming to earth that's cool
and the idea that it's like no one
really knows like where the fourth one
is that it died whatever its body
popping there is that that was actually
great too by the way that direction on
that like a zombie movie like a patient
zero kind of carrier just like slowly it
reminded it follows kind of right that's
slow March I love that yeah super cool
Oh big flaw with that though but later
it's uh but then I then we go to this
whole like scene where we're trying to
learn more about Eddie and we just kind
of see that he's kind of a he kind of
bungles just his whole life but I think
a way that we could have related to
Eddie more and we could have gotten to
the more fun stuff and played with venom
more is if you took out the whole you
know like we got to a point where said
six months later my everything before
that that could have been three lines
that happen later where it was like yeah
I lied to her and I broke into her email
blah blah and that's what happened don't
eat him eat his boss don't need a meet
right anybody it's actually not
important we don't need to know that he
has a relationship with Carlton Drake or
even see that how bad of an of a
reporter he is bright he's really bad
and but if you just jump to him getting
infected and you kind of find out from
there like you unravel it from there I
think we would have spent more time
getting to know the actual character in
this movie that we came for which was
venom
you know is that in every other version
that we've seen Benham show up I'm
talking about like in movies and
animated films and comics forever
you actually don't meet Eddie Brock much
earlier than when he's about to get
venoms like and and he's always down on
his luck but he's having the worst day
of his life
but we don't really need to super
establish how high he was first right he
doesn't need to have his own primetime
Rachel Maddow type show yeah like you
can just have him on his worst day and
then he's going and then he gets covered
in goo yeah well that's one day yeah
that's what I what I mean by when I
think this movie was found in the Edit
right like Tom Hardy said that his
favorite 40 minutes were cut out right
I'm dying to see that movie okay so you
say so you say that and read through
like a bunch of other articles that were
breaking down like what what could that
mean like honestly because like 40
minutes is an insane amount of footage
to just be gutted not what could it
possibly be rated R rated action in
violence yeah that's potentially a full
sequence because I'm telling you there
are parts when this movie's second act
breaks into two I'm talking about this
the part of the movie where Ann Wayne
comes in and there's like there's a
female venom and she kisses him that all
part of the movie there was so much that
was told and not shown where's the first
act of the movie there was so much that
was shown that didn't need to be shown
that could have been told right like
that whole first everything before six
months later but at the end of the movie
we need to know exactly why then amuses
Eddie what about Eddie's personality is
unique also a loser's joke that I
laughed at but like those are critical
things that I believe in this footage
that Tom Hardy's referring to we saw
some super violent sequences where Eddie
and venom realized that they kind of
like working together and that is what
we're afraid if the the symbiote
essentially an upgrade is a means to an
end right he has a purpose that he needs
to fulfill that he can only do with that
help so it's like you know what while I
need to serve this greater purpose I'm
gonna give in to these desires mm-hmm
and he's like I want to take that guy
down like yeah he didn't really care
that before it would have been cool if
we did see something somewhere to
upgrade where it's like it there is a
mission and then I was like cool we'll
do this but then you get to be my like
body bag that we can use to like do
whatever I want after that and also like
the switch the switch between venom
being good bad whatever is super
confusing it doesn't make a lot of sense
but positives from the the positive here
I want you to call it what's your beef
with the storyline of the why did he
change his mind we ID said why you like
you said there was a lot of telling it's
like but why like what your beef with
the passing of the the Oh Oh at the time
so basically we see ambulance the
ambulance worker walk off right and then
that time change hasn't happened yet we
go over to Eddie and hear his story she
comes to that city and she hops in the
old lady and then we get six months
later eight months later whatever and
then she gets to the airport you saying
it took the person who is already in a
populated city who ends up later using a
vehicle can't take a vehicle to the
airport it took her six months after
that point did get to the airport that's
the forty minutes of the movie that was
cut outs insane that made no sense to me
personally let's I think we should talk
about some positive stuff because I want
to talk about the direction in the
performances specifically I think sit
within some of these performances we saw
some really shining moments from this
movie so what do we think about like Tom
Hardy Michelle Williams rosamma these
are great actors right and like it's
actually fascinating to see like yeah
putted great actors together in a movie
that's not really finding anything too
exciting and they can't save it but I he
would I would say everyone in this was
highly watchable which sounds like a
very like low kind of thing to say like
I could look at you but that's why
they're all pretty right but it actually
means that like when they were on screen
I didn't have a desire to like like I
wish they'd go back to that other person
each one of them I was like happy to
hear from them it's just like great
characters in a whatever story yeah I
like and Rizzo meds character is matt
mustache twirling tie a damsel on a
train track kind of villain like he's
not like sue there's no like depth
besides like global warming he doesn't
same thing else past that but I like it
because he
hee hee heightened it a little bit and
like well I didn't feel a threat from
him but I did enjoy like you said I did
like seeing him on screen and I did
enjoy the relationship between and and
Eddie I did like the relationship it's
not perfect but yeah they I guess more
their chemistry the relationship I was
fine with but you can see why uh Tom
Hardy signed on to do this maybe because
this guy's having no shortage of work
he's one of the most wanted actors in
the business and he can probably do any
project that he wants and Sony was
probably thrilled to have him want to do
this part and it's the superhero
franchise movies there's not really Tom
Hardy's normal thing but it's a very
interesting role and he played it very
well I think Tom Hardy's physical
performance in this movie and the way
that he played that kind of fractured
energy of a guy who has like another
presence in his mind that he you know at
one point that him says I will just
consider you my ride right he could see
Tom Hardy being like I'm basically my
what I treat my motorcycle as now and to
be that so you could see him kind of
channel that kind of physical like he
felt like a horse suits and never had a
human right him before and it's just
like what the heck is this get off of me
I like the way ya think when you write a
centaur they're like what and I did it I
enjoyed his performance a lot I think it
liked him more once venom showed up in
him like you get him like a when he's on
the trolley it's like my favorite moment
that I wish they just did more of that
physical comedy they get more of it in
the restaurant but we've done the
trolley venom says hungry and he stands
up amazing Oh goddamn it like it's like
a lot of like he's like it just slips
out he's like no I'm just gonna stand
here right until the trolley stops to
explain to venom it's or whatever it's
just like stop making me do this please
and and his freakout in the restaurant
is such a it's such a good moment as
well where it's just like he he's losing
his mind and I like the way that he
portrayed that specifically and then we
buy the movie I guess he's healthy he's
fine there with everything balanced
remember venom was like dualism then I
can fix this he's like don't worry about
this thing whenever I hear the word
atrophy I always feel like that's a you
missed that there's no turn around
anymore like you you're past the point
of no return and they said his heart had
and I was like all right whatever like
it's aliens in there may be alien goop
will heal that I was like you picked it
you picked an organ that can't like if
they can't like fix normally I don't
know that bugged me in the movie too but
but if we talk about like the tone
set in this movie I think that was kind
of an issue that we were looking forward
I'm not blaming director Ruben Fleischer
who directed Sambi land and a lot of
great stuff he's got a good energy
between like horror and comedy but he it
felt like this is a movie found in the
edit it felt like the studio interfered
a lot in this and unfortunately it seems
like Sony as much as I want a strong
superhero movie does not have a Kevin
Feige or even what DC and Warner had
with Jeff he was all the spider-man
movies yeah he doesn't have like that
kind of balance of like exactly what
fans are looking for when it comes to
fanservice
or maybe doesn't have like the he maybe
has too much restraint yeah it all comes
down to relationships and luckily Kevin
Feige as head of that studio and like a
proven nerd there's let him do whatever
he wants and he lets a director's kind
of have enough control over their movies
so it doesn't feel like too much of the
same thing so it's just a nice balance
there and the other Studios just haven't
lucked into this I would say Fox before
it it's merged with Disney has had a lot
of luck by having like Simon Kinberg
guide a lot of their superhero movies
and doesn't nail it every time it
doesn't nail it every time but I have a
feeling that Dark Phoenix will be like
the surprise superhero hit that we never
thought would ever happen Simon Kinberg
is a guy who pretty much knows what he's
doing I think Days of Future past was as
good as it was because that guy knows
exactly he's the right kind of nerd and
he's the right kind of filmmaker and we
just haven't I mean we think the last
solely produced Sony superhero movie was
the amazing spider-man 2 which had a lot
of similar problems I think that this
movie did I think we just haven't had a
lot of good a corporate groupthink when
it comes to making these movies it's not
just like capturing lightning in a
bottle
they requires a lot of like hand-holding
and shepherding these projects through
well and that's the poem to movie right
is that you can you can see that on the
screen right it's three different movies
or so and it's three different ideas of
how we should do this should this be
funny should this be serious should this
be scary honestly there were horror
elements and that and honestly those are
the ones I responded to the most but
yeah which I but did you find the horror
elements popped up with venom being
there or was it prior to him actually
appearing no I mean it was in the
directing and in the tone I actually
don't think there were many there were
horror elements in the writing of the
script which that could have been
interesting right like imagine if
there's a there's a moment where Eddie
Brock has been separated from the
symbiote and they're in the
same room and the lights are off and
he's trying to like get out of this
building without getting reinfected or
something and like you just know that
like it's around somewhere like just
elements like that would have been
story-wise horror but in the direction I
saw or that I liked obviously again with
that pacing of honestly the whole reason
that that sequence is there of the the
other symbiote slowly making its way to
San Francisco is because of how boring
the first act is it's like remember
though something interesting is coming
yes
did you ever see that movie I think it's
called fallen and you guys can correct
me because you it's with Denzel
Washington yes same premise it's a demon
that transfers the into song but it was
there was such a cool moment where
there's a chase scene with it but Nina
doesn't run it just tapped like touches
the person next to him and they touch
another person so you just see like this
like circuit go through of a tendon
jumping bodies I'm like man I before
this movie came out I knew that riot did
that I was like they gotta do something
like that it's gotta be awesome and he
didn't like showed a glimpse of like but
we could have little girls we're talking
about some of the horror elements and I
think we should move on to talking about
the visuals the aesthetic choices the
cinematography the CGI visually speaking
technically speaking I actually was
again split right like I actually was
pleasantly surprised with my feeling
about venom specifically the way venom
looked I was a little worried that the
chignon venom would make it look CGI
that rubbery feel instead it made it
feel organic I actually like the
separation right at the eyeline with the
like essentially the skin because other
interpretations of venom it's felt like
they're just like painted on almost like
moth wings or something so there's
clearly like a lot of intent there I
really liked it it seemed muscular and
yet inky sticky all those things but
that's actually why I also have beef is
that I prepped man I predicted this
other week I was like I really hope
there's not a moment where it looks like
two ink blots just smashing into each
other and I can't follow what's
happening and that's the third act yeah
if I like when I as a kid had two
different colors of gak and I remember
like oh what happens if they mix and
then you realize it's all ruined and he
start crying
separated nilaam throws it away and
yells yeah it cost four bucks really
broke our house
[Laughter]
I know it's I saw this movie I've seen
it twice you don't have to mm-hmm and I
saw a normal screen a regular movie
theater screen that you guys could see
it on and I thought the CGI was actually
just fine there's moments where it's
like what's happening mainly like the
third act where it's like there's a lot
of these digital zooms and light it's
always like kind of dark and you're not
really sure like what's flying out or
who or who's hitting who at this point
and so you're you kind of like I'll just
wait till this is done to figure out who
lived out of this fight
but I did enjoy but before I then I saw
an IMAX and everything looked awful so
that wasn't that was not a good decision
but before that I liked the idea of in
the final fight of you having the
symbiotes fight over the humans it
looked like they were fighting within
you know like that's kind of cool was
very cool even though you couldn't see
it but like the idea that it's what it
also did illustrate for a second like oh
that one Drew's on that yeah it was
easier to follow actually but it was an
interesting idea that they also had
conflict between them as well I'm really
bummed he didn't see the yellow symbiote
or the blue symbiote we got to see riot
and riot they did make him look more
disgusting than venom just because he
looks like he had scabs all over his
body and like he like freshly healed or
not really but I enjoyed his
visualization but I do like the line
where it's like he's got things you've
never seen yes like a weapon yes that
are big sword small sword spikes ball
with yeah I think we could use some more
inspired character design right if you
think like when you watch like the alien
movies and then granted that's like
comparing like the ultimate best
character design of the xenomorph
creature like you don't need to
necessarily understand the logic of the
biology of it that would help like what
is the biology of the symbiote but like
when you say it has special weapons yeah
it's it'd be more interesting if like
that really wowed us and yeah it's just
you can shape-shift into things that for
some reason venom can't
yeah it's an inconsistent logic right to
the visuals venom was able to form a
fist at one point very clearly and show
like it wasn't Tom Hardy's and it was a
larger big curled finger fist and then
he also knows everything that Tom Hardy
know
and it's like does Tom Hardy know any
other shape other than umbrella like
apparently not right because somehow
riot knows like acts and Mason knows all
these things in it's like venom can't
make that same shape but you can make
you can make teeth and cuz he makes his
own teeth come out and so it's like
that's a sharp object so it doesn't
quite follow what happens but that I'd
be ok with I guess it all comes down to
point of view for me I want to see the
way you see Tony Stark's face when he's
inside the Iron Man suit he's kind of
reacting to things that are happening to
I want to see what's going on through
through Eddie Brock's mind like inside
like he's like I'm sorry I'm sorry I
apologized and you can see I don't know
it maybe even if you peel away his face
and he reacts more to it it's just you
lose that kind of empathy and a lot of
the fight sequences when it's just like
ink rolling around killing and yes it
looks cool but like I think what and I
hate to always go back to the MCU
because they did things that
specifically does mean it's the only
right way but I think you need to have
that human element any time when there's
a fight scene and I mean I guess you
could argue that Hulk you don't really
see him react the monster just kind of
takes over and that's that but there
wasn't enough like dealing with what
venom does well he fights off a head
that like if if you completely make it
that it's venema when you see venom on
the outside Eddie Brock is in zero
percent control then that means that
anything that venom does doesn't
actually matter because we don't really
associate with venom we're not
necessarily thinking like a venom is her
apparently it can't be hurt right aside
from a subwoofer so if if they did
though make it like Eddie Brock is
signing off on these decisions or he's
seen it happen and he's allowing it to
happen then it's like you were a
cannibal for a second there dude like
these are huge things that you're doing
but they took everything that would be
interesting to put a human through and
gave it to the alien yeah well also the
he ate a whole dude at the end in the in
the convenience store because when
they're leaving there's no the night
yeah and in the if you would think that
would be a pretty bloody thing you could
leave a shoe behind you could leave
something to visually convey what
happened this is where I think the
studio is like know anything that could
potentially get it's an r-rating take it
out I think the directors like alright
fine we'll just like cobble too
whatever we can and make this a decent
movie which i think it is a decent
initially it left just a skeleton yeah
it was very good dancing skills exactly
any final thoughts before we move on
from this mmm it definitely like been
said a couple times here it definitely
doesn't deserve the low score that it
has it's fine if you want to see the
movie if you had any interest from any
of the trailers go see it go ahead bring
some friends it'll make it a little bit
more fun the post-credits scenes will
make it more worth your wild because
they are delightful one of them is
specifically and it's fun it'll be a fun
time for you to watch it I think that's
about as much like days this is a fun
popcorn movie and I actually don't
regret having seen it right but that
doesn't mean that like I'd ever see it
again kind of thing yeah I might regret
seeing it twice yeah one of the common
consensus is online is that this movie
feels like it was from like the early
2000 played yeah and I think movie came
out around the same time Sam Raimi's
first spider-man movie I don't think I
would have minded they wouldn't been
like oh cool effects but the thing is
the genre has evolved right like right
we've seen what Marvel's been able to do
in even like some of the bold choices
with like Deadpool and Logan and the
other said I would even say like Zack
Snyder's made some very bold choices
with his movies and the game has changed
you got to bring something new to the
table you can't just go back and be like
I will tell a fairly straightforward
pg-13 superhero movie with some decent
effects you gotta you gotta make a
statement and it has to be there right
the dark themes and the comedy are
nailed in some movies and this is a
movie where we felt like we saw three
movies yeah well let us know what your
thoughts about this so are we being - I
don't think we're being too hard or her
too generous I think and let's hear your
nuanced thoughts in the comments below
because there's a lot to talk about and
yeah we mentioned the post-credits scene
we did another video breaking down the
post-credits scenes in case you have any
questions about that and look forward to
more discussion about venom on this
channel going forward I do want to look
into what was Tom Hardy's cut of this
movie or at least the 40 minutes I'm
very curious to see the deleted scenes
of this movie and maybe there'll be an
Ultimate Edition that will show us this
stuff but for now let's move on to our
trivia question
we have back here so as I read the
question let's just disperse these okay
in the comics there are nine named
symbiotes including venom name as many
as you can ooh okay okay all of our
answers are in the blue bin and as
always we'll reveal the answer at the
end of this video and the winner will
get to her goodbyes the loser will have
to do something
agonizing ly terrible that we'll get to
for now let's move into some other news
this week's he's in thank you the
Daredevils season 3 trailer dropped this
week it's an official full-length
trailer and I'm gonna give you guys a
Leiby baby breakdown if I may alright
with number one daredevil holding the
cross it's the opening scene for the
trailer this is actually based on a very
popular Marvel Knights cover of
daredevil where Marvel Knights is kind
of like the more adult
we're Marvel maxes like super violent
this is like a bit tamer next we why the
costume looks different I actually found
in the born-again story which season
three looks like it's based on during
his recovery Matt while he's in the
Covenant coven they convent convent
thank you who all over the place he goes
into the basement he actually cobbles
together a costume and this is the TV
shows version of that after what's
happened with the defenders also I want
to point out Fisk's white suit which is
more comic accurate everyone wanted to
see in that trademark white suit it also
it seems like he's being born again
after he's getting out of prison after
making that plead metaphorically born
yeah and next it seems pretty clear that
kingpin knows that daredevil and Matt
Murdock are the same person
you actually see them at one point
talking to each other in a bar without
looking at each other which is kind of
fun and I in the comic born again Wilson
Fisk is aware that Matt and daredevil
are the same person which is really
interesting so they're really diving
into that story also
I don't know how kingpin actually makes
out of this season if he does know that
identity of Matt Murdock I will have to
see also some other people's faiths are
up in the air but next having someone
trespass daredevil to kind of you know
disgrace his image and whatnot that's
actually from born again as well we
hidden that comic kingpin hires just a
mental patient to run around with them
shockingly I don't think we're gonna see
that in this TV show but also we've seen
bullseye who has been confirmed to be
this character dress up as daredevil in
the Dark Avengers run which is a really
cool comic book run but next bullseye
has been confirmed for the show and in
this and in this series his alias has
been confirmed to be Benjamin Poindexter
which is my favorite from the comics
it's great nay he will never stand out
in the crowd I also want to point out
this scene where he's holding the gun up
is actually based on another daredevil
comic cover which is very cool it was a
pointed out by reddit user gift 95 but
finally this is like the big thing that
I pulled from this trailer the other
daredevil bull's eye we see him at one
point in the New York bulletin which is
the newspaper that Karen page works for
and also famously in the comics bullseye
is killed Karen page that's one of his
big no-no moments in comics so I don't
think she's gonna be making out of this
season but are you guys excited you can
double the daredevil there's no Elektra
maybe this season and you're getting a
lot more Wilson Fisk compared to season
2 did you guys all watch season 2 yes
I'm daredevil so what are you thinking
how you feeling I I'm excited I I think
this is of the different Marvel Netflix
shows Daredevils the one who that seems
to have the most like tonal consistency
like it knows exactly what the voice of
this show is supposed to be and I I
think the actor in the direction I
actually a really big fan of D'Onofrio
and I think the born-again series is
really the best place to go everyone's
been trying to do a daredevil in a
born-again style right like from the
first one they're like oh we're gonna
use born-again as the inspiration here
it's kind of like the seminal daredevil
series that and like the the Punisher
relationship and I think what's really
good about going this way with the using
the ultimate version of daredevil the
the doppelganger as bullseye what's
really good is I hope that they just
like use it as a only explore bullseye
as his relationship with daredevil is I
think that that was really good about
what the MCU did with Winter Soldier
like they could have explored the Winter
Soldier more but really was about the
relationship between Bucky and Steve and
I think if we can just get the
relationship between these characters of
dirt we'll have to deal with like a non
daredevil bizarro version of him I think
that's the thing that has been most
excited no shame it day and also look at
that jaw line on that boy right right
that's insane that's crazy
this guy's sharp yeah he's probably
gonna like sharpen a little
I'll just add real quick that I'm the
one of the reason I'm excited it's a
little bit of a sad reason but I am I
don't know how much longer these Netflix
Marvel shows are gonna last what the
Disney streaming service coming soon and
with that you know downhill Ness of
their viewership since iron fist
so I point are you because you look like
Danny Rand I think that that means
they're gonna leave it all out there
right they're just gonna like put
everything into this season and just
like balls of the wall and that I'm
really excited for say no the with Luke
Cage and iron fist because I've been the
most recent Netflix series that we've
been able to see they seem to be going
more bite balls-to-the-wall where it's
like Luke Cage they take their character
to a point where it's like if Luke can't
get hurt by anything what actually
happens to a person's character if you
can't be challenged by anyone and that's
interesting
iron fist you open up the the goodie bag
of all the history you can go into and
with daredevil it's like do the story
that everyone wants to do that all of
you have wanted to do for so long so I'm
excited for that also I'm excited to see
how pull bulls like poles like bull's
eye gets his hands on this costume
because they could be a cool showdown
between gladiator who made the costume
for Matt and Matt I think there's gonna
be a cool coming out come in at each
other yeah
well let us know in the comments below
what you're most excited about from this
trailer and yeah and and you know tell
us how you think the whole direction of
these TV show should go should the DC or
the Disney streaming service continue
them or are we looking for like an
outpoint
thanks everybody but now let's move on
to another topic news we obviously we
talked about this a number of times now
on this channel but the fact that
obi-wan and Boba Fett's spin-offs are
now officially canceled it's the first
time that we can report that yeah I
should say that there they've been kind
of rumors still but it really sounds
like it's finally dead yeah basically
you guys remember that Disney's plan was
to release one Star Wars film every year
forever so for the next five years
because it's how long we have left they
were gonna do one big saga release and
then anthology stories or Star Wars
stories the next year or so and so on
and then solo happen right and big
bummer right I mean and like it's not
their fault either right we can I mean
we can actually attest if you
look at our view counts we were able to
see there's a sharp dip whenever we
talked about solo we just say notice
that we're like this is not boding well
for for these movies also weirdly
there's this variety article about
Kathleen Kennedy and in it there's just
this crazy quote that makes no sense
hopefully you guys can figure this out
as of right now no one has been able to
decipher what they meant if this is a
typo or what but the quote is that now
there
Kathleen Kennedy's attention is going to
be directed toward a new core trilogy
beginning with Star Wars Episode nine
directed by JJ Abrams gaining with that
moving with the next Star Wars movie
which is the final one of this trilogy
that we're in that's the quote she's
gonna be focusing on this new trilogy
that maybe she means like movie DB Weiss
and Benioff one is starting after that
trilogy begins cuz they're supposed to
be doing their own trilogy right or is
it just a mistake it's just a typo you
know honestly did she mean episode 10
being directed by Rian Johnson trilogy
right oh he's got so first of all I
don't know if you guys have uh you've
waiting to unlock what the hell this
means I Sam looks like he knows but also
I actually wanted like finally since
we're pretty much here now these movies
that people have been asking for since
honestly the original Star Wars movies
the spin-offs that have always been
pitch right like we'd love to see more
about obi-wan we'd love to see Boba Fett
Boba Fett was probably the one I'd heard
about the most for the longest time yeah
they're officially dead do you guys care
how do you feel yeah well I mean we're
getting the there was some talk of a new
Star Wars series coming out about the
Mandalorian which we'll talk about later
but about Boba Fett so I think my
interest for learning more about
Mandalorians and and boy and bounty
hunters and whatnot I think I'm okay I
am bummed specifically not learning more
about Boba Fett because I have not gone
and read every single comic and every
single legends and every single things
to know what other adventures are out
there for that character and don't be
one like the with the teases of possibly
you McGregor coming back of course I
wanted to see more of him he was my
favorite part of the original series
that in Jar Jar yeah I think Disney and
it's kind of pumping the brakes on the
Star Wars franchise Bob Iger even said
like maybe I rushed out too much too
fast and it's not just so I think there
was like a mix between fan dip and
enthusiasm after the last Jedi despite
how profitable that movie was and then
going into so I don't think that solon
necessarily was a bad movie I don't
think it deserved to like how this thing
of like oh it killed the Star Wars
franchise and killed anthology movies I
think maybe rather than saying these are
canceled I think Disney should just you
know play it safe and just be like we're
just gonna shelve it later write
something happen with New Mutants right
it kept getting pushed back again and
again and again and again and then it
all it came out no I'm so glad it's my
favorite movie the yeah but yeah they
could have just done that right like
it's just on on the side now whatever
but no they're kind of like making it
seem like no you guys didn't show up to
so we're taking this away from you and
it might be like an investor thing -
they're trying to reinsure investors and
just say like JJ Abrams is going to
direct to the episode 9 and just wait
until that comes out and then we can
make new announcements but we still have
yet to see what happens with the ryan
johnson jury yeah that's something
they've been kind of quiet about but
speaking of mandalorian first I'll say I
actually feel like the mandalorian race
has has identified itself is very
interesting throughout all the different
interpretations and honestly like has
become maybe more I've there's stories
that are more interesting than but with
that story so I actually think for me if
scratches that itch but specifically
about the Mandalorian yeah we got some
other news this week an update from some
stuff that's happening with that Jon
Favreau's new series on the DC or keep
seeing DC Disney streaming service yeah
do you think streaming starts to the sea
right yeah in my language it does it's
going to be called the Mandalorian and
he on Instagram posted an actual
synopsis that sounds really great so
it's after the stories of Jango and Boba
Fett another warrior emerges in the Star
Wars universe the Mandalorian is set
after the fall of the Empire and before
the emergence of the first order we
follow the travails of a lone gunfighter
in in the outer reaches of the galaxy
far from the authority of the New
Republic so just to give you some
background on Mandalorians they're like
a super commando warrior people from the
planet Mandell
and if you watch Clone Wars the animated
series you see Mandalorians or
characters in their their most famous
for their armor so like Boba Fett uses
Mandalorian armor infest nest uses a
Mandalorian armor it's like the t-shaped
helmet and they kind of like their armor
either from fallen warriors ends up
getting taken by other warriors and worn
so Bubba Fett is is you know the clone
Jango and Bubba Fett are from we're on
Camino but Boba Fett was like a clone of
him and then later adopted his father as
Mandalorian helmet the head in there and
kept the head in there where is it like
a mask now so what do we do
are we excited it does it sound like a
good idea and is this like do we feel
like there's enough new ground to fill
out a full like hundred episode series
of this but absolutely cuz this thing is
gonna be covering a lot of the canceled
movies right it's gonna like be like
everything that's between there's
probably Jon Favreau's territory now
you'll have jungle book stuff in there
a Lion King as well there's a lot of
good stuff in there this is such a cool
premise that I immediately am like oh
I'm on board war like I'm course I'm
getting the Disney if you think I have
any self-control of course Oh hundred
dollars a month I'm just keep watching
Dumbo over and over again live-action
that animated the live-action then
animated now this show seems amazing
also look at how just clean-cut that
costume is it's amazing and I'm excited
that they're like and we're not going
anywhere near at the Empire who cares
let's go do something else
please can we learn about new things in
these movies in the show and that's
exciting Jon Favreau does a really good
job with characters and making you
relate to not just the main character
but what they mean to everyone else
around them so who is who is his band of
people going to be or is he like a Bruce
Banner in the Incredible Hulk like TV
show we just went town to town to town
and like then that's maybe what he's
doing is just doing like not odd jobs
there he's murdering people but like I
think that's such a cool premise for
show and the directors that they've
already teased for this show are so cool
that like per episode
they've teased like Deborah Chow who
worked on a lot on Jessica Jones I know
you guys were excited about a psycho
Motiti yeah for me where as soon as I
saw tight guy wasn't actually thinking
immediately thor ragnarok i was thinking
oh man this could be like firefly with
murder yeah
which I would love and Bryce Dallas
Howard as well as one of the other
directors they tease but Jon Favreau's
is gonna be he's gonna obviously be
directing like the pilot and like the
finale or whatever and he's gonna have
his hands in this and I think just like
there's something super special about
the show now that could let us down a
lot but I know this is the first Star
Wars thing since I was a kid that I've
actually genuinely been really excited
about so feels fresh and new and you
know I think there is they're gonna pour
money into this thing because I think
Disney's streaming service is going to
be a major competitor against or it's
just think pretty much there's 60
percent of what you watch is gonna have
to be accessed through this app right
and they have to say that they're gonna
outdo Netflix right because that's their
whole their whole thing is like we don't
need to be on Netflix so Netflix is
spending eight billion dollars a year
that's a real figure on original content
yikes Disney's probably gonna get close
I mean Apple even with their new
streaming services is already doing a
dollars around there I think they're
gonna pump it with Game of Thrones money
they also I think when we were talking
about the Marvel shows like the Loki and
the Scarlet Witch and everything for the
Disney I feel like how could they get
that money and then you hear these
directors and you see like the
production value immediately because
they're already shooting the show you're
like I'll never mind like if you easily
get that and a couple other MCU actors
and zpz I'm this app is going to blow
our minds probably let us know what you
think about this show and let's move on
to some other interesting news that came
out through re watches this week right
with am in the wasp yeah you guys were
hitting this up a lot about this and
it's actually an easter egg that we
talked about before on this channel but
we do want to revisit it because there's
a little bit more on it but in ant-man
and the wasp in the quantum realm look
at that that's a tiny little city
someone pointed it out but also
specifically they pointed out that it
could kind of look like the tiny city
and Avengers end times if you look that
up
it's 2010 comic it's issue number 32 32
so BAM but we can throw out theories for
what we think this is gonna be but
actually I know Eric you've covered this
in previous video you remind us what
we've already kind of senses this is
from the new blue where a HD released so
we can see it so in so much better
detail now at first I would just say if
you like is that just a blur or we just
like making shapes out of you know were
shocked ink blots
but yeah so we
did go into this a little bit in our
breakdown we made another video about
like with different areas so in the
Marvel Comics there's this part called
the micro world or Microverse also knows
subatomic ax and there's it's really one
of these things too where it's like
Stanley like but it kind of starts with
like the Fantastic Four characters and
with a you know Doctor Doom shrinks them
and they go somewhere and then like
ant-man has to go save them and they end
up turning the tables on Doctor Doom and
he just disappears but then later he
shows back up
apparently all this time he was in micro
world he like conquered this planet
called Mir wood there's all these
interesting stuff there's even at one
point the thing goes missing in in the
in the subatomic universe where like
he's kind of they find him as Scott Lang
finds him later where he's like a thor
ragnarok style hulk gladiator and he's
become a little star but it sounds like
it's one of these things that just kind
of just become because comics right like
right it's not like a secret protection
over these stories so I think the most
interesting implication of it is that
there could be another universe down
that where there are civilization right
well in the most practical application
of this is Scott Lang uses this right he
goes in there any I see as a payphone
any rescue for sure and I think what one
of the things I started look at is wait
are you saying they introduced that in
the new Avenger Tommy oh my god better
be so like I like oh wait hold on we
have to grasp this getting a tiny phone
call we already have the raccoon who's
just even better than this and I'll
sketch I think what we should look at
this as rather than just like a small
universe imagine if it's just like when
Scott Lang was going between atoms it
opens up a portal to another realm so
what if there's a tenth realm the way
they have the nine realms of like the
the Thor universe and this just another
realm because we know Stephen strange
went blasting through it as if it were
just another dimension so what if what
if down in that city they just got a
wormhole and you jump into it you pop
out on on Sekar or something you know we
could it's weird if you look into
theoretical physics there's all these
theories about like how inner space is
governed by the same theoretical physics
as
to space and yeah you could just put
drop in an einstein-rosen bridge they
just go through it and then they aren't
small anymore they yeah can we go back
to the picture real quick because I also
want to point out that there is a little
more science here another you strike if
you look to the upper right corner of
the circle you'll see that there's a
mosquito and amber and I just connected
the Jurassic Park universe to this right
this moment
yeah that's Robbie that's the thumbnail
also I'm a big fan Mark Waid recently
did an ant-man the wasp series with
Scott Lang and they're new they didn't
for some reason made a new wasp didn't
name her hope they named her Nadya so
anyway it's basically like based off the
movie they go to like subatomic micro
world stuff and they start playing with
Theodoric theoretical physics and
particles and they start acting like
those particles it's a very interesting
story ant-man 3 you should probably base
it off that was a really good story yeah
so yeah this is very interesting fine
but what other big news don't worry I
got you covered because Zack Snyder
confirmed on vero everyone's favorite
social media platform that he'll and
hold on to your hats kids he planned to
kill off Batman in his version of the DC
EU but also we got some set photos that
surfaced of Jake Gyllenhaal as Mysterio
in spider-man far from home and a most
Mysterio of all he did not have his
fishbowl helmet Oh Eric also did a whole
video about this so be sure to check
that out also fun fans for a fun fact
for fans of Game of Thrones Jon Snow's
direwolf ghost will be back for the
final season with a fair amount of
screen time according to the VFX
supervisor he makes it as well and
finally black marrows black mirror
season 5 will include a
choose-your-own-adventure episode as
Netflix tries to expand the usage of
this feature I did a little research
they tried this one time on a in boots
animated show we can choose the ending
so one episode is gonna try it
I am extremely interested to see what
the options could possibly be they're
probably all going to be depressing well
and it definitely puts us as part of the
black mare story and I feel like we're
just like that's it now we are gonna die
yes black mare thing on Yuki do ya all
right well let's move on to some
lightning round questions you guys know
how this works you sent us some great
questions I'm gonna try them on my
co-host I got some questions for myself
in here too we have to answer them
quickly all right it's gonna be true
lightning around no education what's
already here we go first question for me
at Bruce gamefreak wants to know do you
think that the whole Disney Fox merger
will be complete by the time of interest
for comes out in 2019 absolutely not
they shot that movie a year ago and that
deal wasn't going through but man I wish
they could I'd love to have x-men in
that movie Sam at the dragon wreath
reborn so with Chris Evans leading
Captain America role who steps up as the
next big leap I wouldn't mind to see
Bucky hopping up there but if we go with
the new character it's gonna be our
Black Panther Captain Marvel or
spider-man yes I mean lightning like I
hate oh potato we know that person if
you and your fellow co-hosts or a
superhero team what would your team name
be Sam at the wheel TK 12 wants to know
if you could choose any pop culture
weapon to take with you in battle what
weapon would you choose portal gun we're
going great Phyllis and Joel's worth
once no quick what rhymes with Kevin
Feige Hyman oh YP no which would you
rather have won a ridiculously small
bladder causing you to go to the
bathroom three times during any movie
you see or two only being allowed to sit
in the front row of any movie so front
row oh I don't want to use the bathroom
at all I've almost wet my pants a couple
times all the way through others say I'm
a dad NAB Trix wants to know what are
you going to be for Halloween I surprise
surprise it's from the office and it's
nitch same person wants to know what are
you going to be for Halloween one of
those lesbians from The Dark Knight
Returns sure great and at Sunday duck
which is your favorite movie before 1970
Oh 2001 Space Odyssey 69 our name would
be heart attack because we're coming at
ya
Valachi man yeah great thank you for all
this questions hopefully we answered
yours and keep firing them at us every
week we're gonna try to be more engaging
and interactive with you guys we love
hearing from you
let's move under a 15-second shout out
where we get to shout out plug a rant
about anything we want Sam you got
something yes I want to talk about
maniac it's the limited series from from
cary fukunaga on netflix and it stars
Jonah Hill and Emma Stone the story is
really interesting and I like that it's
kind of an unreliable narrator so far
what's happening only two episodes in
but so far the aesthetic is just um
there's a lot of like stranger things so
you kind of feel comfortable in the
easiest etic it the premise of this show
is like something happened to the 90s so
everything looks like the 90s and it's
not even like super like excited I'm not
excited about it but it's something
really soothing to watch and I'm
actually invested to see where this
mystery goes that's not it doesn't feel
very straightforward so check out I can
finally say I kind of accidentally
plugged it too early but it wasn't up
yet on scenar so go to senior
consolation rockstars I have a Breaking
Bad breakdown but it's a super in-depth
analysis so if you're super fan I like
analyze the script that pilot episode is
one of the best design pilots of all
time I explain why for an hour and you
gotta check that out because like any
breakdown I do hear it's like just a
poor imitation of what Phil was able to
do when he breaks down so definitely go
sanitation of what 15 seconds I want to
shout out I just tweeted it or retweeted
it
the show kidding on on Netflix the Jim
Carrey show they they showed a behind
the scenes take of how they did an
amazing one take shot and I'm all about
those one take shots I love on so cuarón
because he always works one into every
movie but this one they rotated the
camera round where you just see him on
TV and time passes and they change his
set around they put like a
fly-on-the-wall camera where you see and
you hear like the director cueing
different people coming in it looks
fantastic so I love showing how they
come with like all practical ways to do
interesting one take shots as opposed to
like CG one takes fast and furious
you're not proven anything by doing that
answer or answering the question posed
earlier and this one was a tough one we
had a lot of a different and curious
interesting answers that I'm sure
we'll get to that's mine and that's
somehow okay so just remind us of what
the question was is in the comics there
are nine named symbiotes including venom
name as many as you can now let's start
by actually naming all the ones that we
have including with venom so we have
venom and then we have agony phage
Lasher scream and riot those are the
five life foundation ones
there's also carnage toxin and
anti-venom right so how do we do all
right I'll start with Eric uh Eric said
carnage riot phage that's one of them
yeah well you just puts that on the ink
skipped okay scream Lasher agony savage
agent venom the judges are keeping an
unfair track okay sam says riot carnage
venom anti-venom toxin and shriek one
two three four five but only six answers
right and that's important to know going
into Phillips answers right god yes all
mine and he wrote all nine he wrote he's
here yo guys counting down venom riot
carnage symbiote Samba Zazu she right
kylo Bechtold explain so much all right
judges who whine and who I mean that is
all nine okay what Eric did get the most
correct and then between field and Sam I
got more he only got a three they were
right yeah so yeah yeah see the comments
right now so Sam's gonna choose a more
gif of shame bucket he's gonna have to
read and do whatever is on the slip of
paper and then you guys will turn it
into an animated gif in yes yeah
and then we'll feature it so swap out
that green screen when so Sam can be
anywhere you want him to be it doesn't
have to be what it is so Sam tell us
what you got act like there's an alien
bursting out of your chest oh wow that's
a fun like know she's that kind of God
so here's what we'll do I'll read the
goodbye Sam will do this and he's gonna
look like a fool so turn them into
anything you want doesn't have to be an
alien
that'd be too hard to pop out of it
chest oh look at him go
okay everyone shame shame thank you for
watching this week's episode of new rock
stirrers news and let us know your
thoughts on venom and all the other
stuff that we talked about in the
comments below let's thank our host Sam
basher at Sam bachelor on Twitter
there's also me Eric vas at ei vas on
Twitter and Phillip Molina at FEMA on
Twitter oh look at that
wow you guys are really good with that
current production so now I've got post
in real time wow we're it's like we're
on a set of the Mandalore and comment
down below in tweet of Sydney rockstars
like this video share it around
subscribe to new rock stars through the
deep dives into all the stuff that you
love good bye everyone
[Laughter]